atualmente o nosso país existem três
tipos de mundo
o mundo é que nós vivemos num mundo com
acesso à tecnologia acesso à educação
acesso à informação acesso à cultura
acesso ao lazer
esse mundo um outro mundo
o mundo paralelo que recebe esse
adjetivo de paralelo porque está na
esquina na periferia na favela dos
lixões
esses dois mundos embora se vejam não se
enxergam
para que esse mundo em que nós vivemos
com todos esses acessos enxerga o mundo
paralelo
é necessário que a gente saia do nível
de consciência da dormência e vá para o
desperto existe outra forma de se ver o
que acontece quando o conflito entre os
dois mundos
geralmente pela violência e aí vem a
discriminação mas esse mundo paralelo
não é o pior dos mundos existe um igual
ou talvez um pouquinho mais penoso o
mundo invisível habitado por seres
humanos informação que por sua natureza
são indefesos e pela ação humana são
invisíveis
esse mundo chama-se o mundo invisível
das instituições de acolhimento das
crianças e dos adolescentes habitado
hoje no nosso país ou cerca de 45 mil
crianças e adolescentes
mas de onde vem a idéia desse mundo como
ele se materializou
e como tudo no nosso país uma ideia
brilhante viram a lei formidável mas que
na prática não alcança a essência da
norma
esse mundo chamado instituição de
acolhimento foi criado para que as
crianças e os adolescentes que estão o
que vão ficar em situação de
com suas famílias naturais com as suas
famílias biológicas sejam de lá
retiradas pelo estado brasileiro e
colocadas nessa instituição onde será
garantido todos os seus direitos
exceto de convivência familiar porque a
instituição não é igual à família mas é
pra ser temporário
a instituição de acolhimento
nessa ideia fantástica de tirar a
criança do risco
ela tem que ser temporária para a
criança eo adolescente
essa é a razão de existir quando a
criança chega o estado brasileiro tem
que verificar vai voltar para a família
natural biológica
será que o estado brasileiro consegue
destruir aquela família consegue da
orientação educação o suporte social
para modificá la
e aí sim receber como prioridade a
criança o adolescente que de lá foi
retirado
essa é a prioridade é voltar para sua
família natural tem uma segunda opção
quando essa não se materializa é a opção
de ter alguma família com parentesco com
a criança eo adolescente mas que tenham
vínculo afetivo e que lá possa ser
inserida sem está em situação de riscos
essas duas opções ainda não foram
materializadas existe uma terceira opção
uma família que queria pegar aquela
criança é aquele adolescente e colocada
com mais um membro da família como se
filho fosse sem nenhum tipo de distinção
recebendo com amor com carinho a atenção
de forma irrevogável e irretratável logo
definitiva através da adoção
a idéia formidável não fosse uma
realidade diferente
hoje uma criança que chega na
instituição de acolhimento
se ela tem até três anos segundo os
dados do conselho nacional de justiça
dos grupos de apoio à adoção em média de
três anos do sexo feminino
dos olhos claros dos cabelos claros e
saudável
o estado brasileiro em tempo hábil
consegue resolver a situação dessa
criança
mas essa criança ea cores cura ela não é
saudável ou seja se é deficiente física
mental ou portadora de alguma síndrome
comunais incurável com cura de difícil
conquista pela medicina
essa criança fica à margem da queles que
estão cadastrados querem adotá la
ela deixa de ser um hóspede temporário
passa a ser um residente permanente ea
instituição de acolhimento não é família
como é que essa criança entra em regra
cláudia
como é que ela consegue adentrar nesse
mundo invisível
as histórias são pesadas as histórias
são tristes violência física queimada
por cigarros violência física com a
fivela do cinto que ficou a marca em sua
pele violência sexual que às vezes geram
a gravidez de uma menina de 9 e 10 anos
tudo com participação da sua família
natural violência psicológica abandono
porque é deficiente física abandono
porque tem uma deficiência mental porque
é portadora de hiv e se abandona no chão
ou na esquina uma lata de lixo
a história já mostra que os nossos
semelhantes ali já estão fragilizados
o estado brasileiro se preocupa muito
com o meio ambiente ótimo fantástico e
um semelhante para poder habilitar o
meio ambiente
a instituição de acolhimento por mais
maravilhosa que seja ela não vai ser
família e não temos instituição de
acolhimento maravilhosa
em que pese todos os profissionais que
lá trabalham que se dedicam e que tentam
fazer da instituição de acolhimento um
lar
falta estrutura e é fácil explicar a
criança não vota
imagina as políticas públicas para
chegarem nas instituições de acolhimento
onde estão as crianças e os adolescentes
pode piorar pode piorar
e quando essa criança fica maior de
idade
abrem se as portas das instituições
ela sai do mundo invisível e vai pro
mundo paralelo drogas primeiros furtos
crimes mais complexos morte prematura
deixa de ser invisível e passa a ser um
bandido a escória da sociedade porque a
sociedade falhou e porque tem tratamento
diferenciado de crianças nas
instituições de acolhimento porque a
nossa sociedade ainda preconceituosa
vendemos a história que o brasil é um
país heterogêneo é um país de mistura de
raças mas não aceitamos nos diferentes
das nossas famílias
quando nos identificamos como pais
adotivos dizem que pena
você não pode ter filhos há como você é
uma pessoa maravilhosa você fez um ato
de caridade
acreditamos ainda que as questões
psicológicas e de caráter são passadas
pelo sangue preconceito com a adoção com
a raça com a cor com a situação social e
econômica
ficar na instituição de acolhimento por
muito tempo é tão ruim que basta entrar
lá por cinco dez minutos
a primeira vez que entrei e saí chorando
e onde é que tá que esse mundo invisível
porque as crianças que lá estão
acolhidas são tocadas pelo pó mágico
chamado segredo de justiça
o segredo de justiça os nossos filhos
fantástico maravilhoso protege
estão em casa nos nossos vários conforto
com amor mas para as crianças que estão
instituição de acolhimento é o invisível
eu não posso passar nenhuma imagem delas
aqui no ted
seria fantástico talvez um pai adotivo
aqui surgisse ou no mundo onde nós
estamos sendo vistos não posso fazer
isso porque o segredo de justiça se
impede nem os nomes dessas crianças com
seus dados nos cadastros
a sociedade tem acesso a uma sociedade
que já têm preconceito da adoção uma
sociedade que já não querem enxergar o
mundo paralelo de acordo com seu nível
de consciência poderia pelo menos a
olhar uma criança adolescente nesse
mundo invisível fazer com que ela saísse
tivesse um lar tivesse uma família
mas nem tudo é dor o ted aqui é para o
bem e sendo para o bem
eu posso dizer que há 25 anos atrás uma
pequena quantidade dessa sociedade que
ainda preconceituosa resolveu adotar e
ao tirar seus filhos da instituição de
acolhimento esses pais adotivos virão
com os seus coleguinhas lá ficaram com a
realidade triste e tentaram fazer a
diferença e fizeram a diferença
há 25 anos foi criado um movimento
nacional da adoção
esses seres maravilhosos criaram
instituições maravilhosas que são
chamados grupos de apoio à adoção e
instituições sem fins econômicos se
vínculos políticos partidários sem
vínculos religiosos que trabalham
voluntariamente e trabalho voluntário
não é trabalha de graça não é o que se
paga para trabalhar porque a gasolina é
o papel é tudo que se faz para que
aquela criança seja salva em uma família
esses grupos de apoio à adoção cresceram
tanto que hoje no brasil a gente tem
cerca de 150 um pouquinho mais em
algumas capitais têm mais de um aqui em
natal nós temos o projeto acalanto natal
do qual eu tenho uma profunda honra de
fazer parte há 15 anos
esses grupos de apoio à adoção
instauraram no brasil uma cultura de
adoção
mesmo com todo esse preconceito e os
números aqui por exemplo do rio grande
do norte dentro do projeto acalanto
natal mais de 1300 crianças beneficiadas
mil e trezentas crianças que tiveram a
família e que hoje estão salvas
eu sou pai pela via da doação
a maior experiência da minha vida
aconselho a todos porque palavras eu não
vou conseguir alcançar aquilo que eu
senti voluntário do grupo de apoio à
adoção
faço parte da garra da associação
nacional dos grupos de apoio à adoção
tem feito a diferença fantástica em
relação a essas crianças desse mundo
invisível
tive experiências únicas chorei e chorou
muito por essas crianças e adolescentes
nas instituições de acolhimento com
aquele olhar de tristeza à espera de uma
família mas chorei e chorou muito de
alegria toda vez que aquele pequenino
rosto entra em uma família com aquele
sorriso fantástico tive a oportunidade
de conhecer essas pessoas maravilhosas
que criaram esses grupos dentre elas o
doutor luiz skate um grande psicólogo
o estudioso da adoção do estado de
pernambuco e uma célebre frase dele eu
deixo para vocês todos os filhos
biológicos
todos os filhos são adotivos são
biológicos porque a única forma de
existir são adotivos porque a única
forma de amar aquele que produz o que
cria o que gera seu filho e não adota
não ama não constitui uma família
a partir dessa frase eu me conhece e eu
percebi que eu existo só para amar nós
existimos apenas e simplesmente para o
amor
as conquistas materiais são boas são
necessárias para ter uma vida
confortável mas o que importa é aquilo
que a gente faz em relação ao amor que
está em potência dentro da gente dentro
de cada um de nós
eu espero que os presentes aqui e
aqueles que estão nos vendo pelo mundo
possam ter a semente do desconforto do
desconforto de uma realidade dura e da
incapacidade de pensar poxa eu ainda não
fiz nada
esse desconforto é o primeiro passo do
amor e que vem o segundo passo que
procurem saber mais sobre esse mundo
invisível sobre os grupos de apoio à
adoção e um terceiro passo gigantesco
que sejam famílias adotivas no futuro
quem sabe
os filhos de vocês hoje já estão
invisíveis nas instituições de
acolhimento do brasil e que esse amor
floresça e vem à tona agora no coração
de todos
eu tive a experiência de adoção no
estado de ceará fortaleza
uma criança que andava na instituição de
acolhimento rastejando então não mandava
esteja lo e essa criança já tinha o a
aids manifesta e um casal que ela
visitou a instituição de acolhimento que
teve a oportunidade de ver aquela
criança nem pensavam em adotar
ela tem até diziam que queria adotar mas
dentro daquela perspectiva de um bebê e
branquinho
quando eles chegaram lá olhar para
aquela criança aquela criança de um
sorriso espontâneo e depois eles me
falaram
ali eu reconheci a minha filha porque eu
vi no sorriso
a atitude do amor despertar no meu
coração
hoje essa criança anda e como eu fiz a
adoção do processo de adoção
eu recebei ano passado presente e muita
emoção que levou às lágrimas que foi um
travesseirinho com a fotografia dela o
convite que eu faço hoje façam parte
dessa história com amor
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]